Và mình thích thành chính, tưởng bảo ra gà xa quét qua các đặc khua hàng chính hôm gông và mắc cao của Trung Quốc,
khiến 2 khu vực này bị tây liệt.
Tại hôm gông, mục quét sạm hàng sang bị sống đánh vửa cửa kính,
cơ quan lý tây sắc nhận in nhất chính mình ở bị thương.
Chính quyền đi nhận hơn, bà chính là mới chính hợp kê độ,
mời ơi, một vụ phạm một vụ sạt lất,
mà cao, mơ lớn đã gây nghiệp sâu tới 1 phy năm nay,
tại nhiều khu vực trưởng thất.
Quảng người sống như nùa dịch điện hưởng giống mất địa,
sau khi chính quyền mục phạm nương công các diện để bảo vệ ăn quan.
Bảo ra gà xa cũng đã thêm sang như thế hạnh mạng này tại đang hoàn,
với nhất mùi bệnh người thêm mặt, 1, 2, 3, 1, tích.
Tần cầm có 2 chỗ dân để đi xa tảm.
Một dù cạnh bảo bảo bảo đất hạ tự các mời dù các tảm.
Khi mảo dự khởi khu vực,
sông cơ quan khi tưởng vẫn suy chỉ kính bảo só mạnh kệm nướn,
quyền cáo người dân hạn chỉ sang hoài và chính xa khu vực bên diện.
Hoàn nương sau bảo ra gà xa đừng dự bảo vẫn tìm mạnh quyết cơ mơ lớn,
ghê thêm sáng bạng cho đôi sống và sảo thông.